une réunion de travail où se
construisent de nouvelles passerelles
entre les îles françaises et ses voisins
de la caraïbe sept professionnels sont
pour certains des porteurs de projets
docteur à thala et cardiologue
il fait partie des 17 candidats qui ont
réfléchi sur l'aide à apporter en
matière d'offre de soins dans la région
caribéenne lui dallas miami ou d'aller
en angleterre ce geste par exemple
mettre le pacemaker c'est ma spécialité
ça sera fait en martinique ou en
guadeloupe ça coûtera 2 à 3 fois moins
cher et ça sera fait dans de bonnes
conditions sont les voisins sont des
voisins
il ya l'exemple de la cardiologie et
bien d'autres projets ciblés et en
adéquation avec les défis de recherche
de formation et de prise en charge du
patient
on a le projet de dépistage de la
drépanocytose donc nous avons des
centres de référence donc sur nos
territoires et nous aidons les pays de
la caraïbe à dépister et ensuite à
prendre en charge la drépanocytose bien
sûr sur ces territoires là des travaux
sur l'oncologie le registre des cancers
en martinique qui particulièrement
dynamique et qui travaille avec les
états de la caraïbe sur ce sujet là des
projets aussi sur la gériatrie
une coopération qui se construit grâce à
des fonds européens
plus de 5 millions d'euros sont dédiés à
ces différents projets dont plus de 1
million trois cent mille euros pour la
martinique
les établissements ont à travers ce
programme la possibilité justement
d'avoir une stratégie gagnant gagnant
aussi c'est vers ces deux sortes de
mieux organiser leur filière l'idée est
effectivement de profiter de cette
restructuration pour améliorer le
fonctionnement et la qualité des
services de développer peut-être des
filières de façon différente et aussi
d'augmenter le volume d'activité qui
réalisait sur l'île parce que on est
face à des quotas d'actes face à des
autorisations pour lesquelles il est
important pour nous d'avoir un bassin de
population et donc
des recrutements pour les traitements
plus important l'organisation des états
de la caraïbe orientale l'eau a eu ses
hauts souhaite elle aussi approfondir
cette coopération la discussion
commencée en novembre dernier se
poursuivront pendant au moins deux ans